hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the long eyed project
chapter one and two if you wanted more
analog horror this is one of those and
if you want to run away now it's too
late you've already clicked on the video
and you're in it with me until the
bitter end if you don't remember what
analog [ __ ] is here's a reminder
okay cool now we're all caught up to
date
all right
is
is made specifically for special secret
services
after a couple of seconds you will be
presented with an example image of the
creation we call this long eyed
we use the image carefully
i don't know if i want to view the image
carefully
ah
i don't want to
i'm looking but i don't want to look
i don't like the way it's looking at
image to be me normal we advise you to
close this training program
for your own mood for my own okay
but why would i want to do that
if you consider this image unnatural
or not adequate causing panic
vomiting
blood from bones
you think you are fit for crying you
think i'm fit for trading if i've got
blood oozing from wounds
various wounds that have just appeared
on my body the essence of training is to
develop your thick sense
you will be shown a series of images to
each
your task is to draw mine whereas the
creature impersonating a human
if you feel someone's presence nearby
bracing behind your back
immediately close the training program
and pray i'd pray
how about run
how about maybe run
hi
oh
what am i making a choice of what is ah
you know just
not very long eyes here very long eyes
here you know
i'm gonna go with this one
my ass familiar hey
hey you the thing i yep
okay
hi
hello
okay
um well this guy's face kind of squished
this guy's got a long face
but honestly he could be normal like
this could be just this guy's face and
he's got a long face it's long eyes not
long face something about this one rubs
me wrong i don't know why but i don't
like this the eyes are way too low
i'm gonna go with that
great work thank you
you have successfully passed the first
verification stage
there are more tests ahead of you
if at some point you begin to feel that
something is not going according to plan
turn off the training program and don't
turn around for a while and i'll help
you why i've have your camera looking
behind me the whole time
does that count i don't mean to turn
around
faces some tips that will likely save
your life
their face looks unnatural
they give off a bad smell
they're called feelings of an exceed
they're watching you closely
uh
okay
and don't turn around for a while
hi
hello
[Music]
[Music]
hi hi grandma
okay you look relatively normal but not
normal
grandma you just look old honestly
grandma seems like just a grandma
i'm gonna go with you hi hello oh don't
look at me look see a nice workout if
you put something behind me
i feel someone's presence in the room i
think something's looking at me
am i alive if i mean maybe am i
captain
[Music]
am i alone well are we or any of us
actually
well i mean i'm collectively with you
guys but you know what this is a
recorded video so whatever happens to me
might have already happened if i am not
here at the end of this video that you
know what happens
hi
hello
okay well
yeah
this looks like you had some bad
photoshopping of the face i think you're
okay
some ain't right here
okay
hi
oh
[Laughter]
what a strong chin you have
voldemort
what are you doing
[Music]
hey sup hi sup okay well this is strange
they both look
the [ __ ] is that
the [ __ ] is behind you right now
what the [ __ ] you got
anyway um
hell
sure
i don't know
i'm starting to think that they might
all be
long ides what
hey
don't open don't open my feelings don't
open my
hi hi
oh hi
um hi uh
just gonna i i don't think that there's
any wrong answers here
hi
hello
this doesn't even look like a
yep i don't know i don't know man
i don't know
thank you
no thank you congratulations
you've passed the test
your score will not be disclosed for
data protection purposes
why
they will come for you within a week
don't go outside don't talk to anyone
don't open the doors don't answer calls
if you are not contacted within seven
days
pray am i not supposed to open that door
you know this is a common theme
for those of you who have watched in
space with markiplier which if you
haven't
watch it don't open any doors that's
kind of like the general rule
okay that was chapter one this is
chapter two
[Music]
so
this is a different part of the test
welcome if you're listening to this
message you have successfully passed a
long eyed accent thank you
congratulations i appreciate it so you
will be connected to the senior partner
i sent you
she brought you up today
[Music]
and i've been yes
as your senior parker
i was told that you still don't fully
understand what's going on here no so i
will tell you a little
these creatures they um
how can i explain this way
however these creatures are just like
humans
but they cause discomfort and looks
unnatural
my experience in this organization
showed that they are often directly
related to the disappearance of people
and do not leave any traces
and there is always a terrible smile at
the crime place
okay
i was giving your address here with the
old information about you
let me tell you the trust
and from birth you are under our control
so
um so what i'm talking about
how exactly did you finish your interest
exam i hope well because i will be
scared to work with
an experienced person
how people say
i passed the exam with and they
collected me after so yeah let's go with
that one
okay
perfectly i'm glad that you are honest
with me because from this day we are
partners and must trust each other
so let me explain what our job is
partner partner
so our work was used not to write those
places from where people call the police
no
we listen to audio recordings of the
nine element calls
and then look at the photos attached to
the case
it depends on my choices and yours how
many people will die from their hands
or how many people we will save
huh
let's i'm still extremely confused as to
what i'm actually doing here
first case
9-1-1
what is your emergency
um hello i have a child standing across
the road he's looking straight at me
it's been about an hour now
sir stay on the line describe in more
detail what's wrong with the child
um she this kid he's scary
i can't describe him he has a face
small too small eyes
find a narrow smile why the hell
i send the police to your others
can you go to the child and ask if he
needs help
why hell no i'm not going to this
[ __ ] what is he doing alone in the
street at 3 am
sir do you understand that if the child
will be in the injury
and you do not help him
then it will be a crime no no not
necessarily
not necessarily yes of course i
understand but
i just can't i
well
that was him
i will try to approach him
i will be right back
sir
sir are you here
everything is good
okay
[Music]
okay um
voice acting aside uh i'm gonna assume
that this one that you've told me before
is bad
is bad
9-1-1
ready to listen to you hello
something is making noise in my house
the fact is that i leave alone i'm
scared do you have any pets
could that be them um no i don't have
any animals
i think someone broke into my house
sent someone please addresses
okay sir stay calm
i called the police at your others
can you hide somewhere and take
something for self-defense yeah
i'm in the kitchen uh i'll take a knife
and hunt behind the table if it comes
out i'll try to take a picture of the
robber
great stay on the line the police are on
the way
oh god i are sorry
i
kind of took a picture of it it seems to
have noticed me i'll try to run out in
the street
sir everything is good
answer
[Music]
it's kind of hard to take seriously with
the voice acting the way it is
um so i'm gonna forgive it for that i'm
gonna keep going through it because what
in the
what is what is that
what is that well he's just got a
nosebleed that ain't right
that ain't right some ain't
hello
oh
okay
this place okay
hi
okay
all right cool
that's fine
probably
further calls are not available the data
is classified continue choosing um
hey
hi what a beautiful smile you have what
a beautiful and terrifying smile you
have
hey
are you the one that was just laughing i
bet i bet i bet
oh my god
what happened to you
what happened to you
all right oh my god
oh my god oh hey how you doing
wow
was it you laughing were you the one
chuckling up a storm over there
[Music]
uh
attention this is not a test alert the
database is under their danger if you do
not believe in god keep it's time to
believe keep working in praying okay
[Music]
i'm being imbued with power
ah okay
what
which of these did i saw in my dream
answer honestly
um well i've never really had a dream a
playground but i'm sure i've had school
dreams so i'm gonna go with this
i don't know how this protect am i lying
no
no no
am i alone well in accordance with my
last answer i'm gonna go with no on that
one
i have to go with no
[Music]
all
right oh oh boy
hi
hello
director sent me your performance
records
you're doing great give it up
i'll put in a good word for you for a
raise
thank you now we can watch them more
closely
see you later
oh
i got the good end
[Music]
what would happen if i get the bad and i
don't know if this is probably gonna
take a while to do
i don't even know how i get the bad end
okay
i'm gonna guess it wants me to pick that
i'm not gonna pick it
boom
okay so i made this choice before i'll
make this choice
which is probably fine
you
i choose you
i choose you
[Music]
i choose you
answer honestly uh let's go with this
one
am i lying
yeah
you got me i'm lying
am i alone
oh yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah
am i sure if i'm alone
no not anymore
oh oh
hey
[Music]
up a lot
we are in big trouble now
but it's really going to pay attention
to my voice i'm a little sick
but
that's not about it now
so tell me how you messed up so much
with trees of cronkite
wow wait
wow wait who the [ __ ] are you
[Music]
okay
frank frank
my buddy
i guess i better open that door
let me just reach over and open it
hey frog
[Music]
you